she's ever make anything happen anything
you couldn't explain you're a wizard
Harry I'm a what
dear mr. Potter we are pleased to inform
you that you have been accepted at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry in a few moments you will pass
through these doors and join your
classmates keep an eye on the staircases
they'd like to change
good afternoon cars welcome to your
first flying lesson stick your right
hand over the broom and say you really
have to stop
why did mr. Potter our new celebrity
first-years should note that the dark
forest is strictly forbidden
with no magics to be used between the
classes in the corridors
the third-floor corridor is out of
bounds to everyone who does not wish to
suffer a most painful death understand
this sorry because it's very important
not all Wizards are good
I'm gates bad for either of you come up
with another clever I did it is killed
was expelled see nice saw her priorities
I think it is clear and we can expect
great things from you